مره اخرى تسجل دوائر الصحه في الناصريه
جنوب العراق حالات اصابه بالحمى النزفيه
الفيروس الذي ينتقل عبر الملامسه من
الحيوان الى الانسان عن طريق الحشرات
والبعوض وكان العام الماضي تسبب في وفاته
اربعين شخصا واصابه
378 محافظه ذي قار خلال الربع الاول من
عام 2023 خمسه اصابات بمرض الحمى النزفيه
من ضمنها ثلاثه
وفيات
الاصابات في هذا الوقت نوعا ما مبكره جدا
مما ينذر
بموسم قاسي
واحتماليه كبيره لتفشي مرضي مع ارتفاع
درجات الحراره
توضح الدوائر الصحيه في جنوب العراق خطوره
هذه الامراض المعديه وكيفيه تسببها بعلل
شديده تهدد حياه الانسان مثلي تلف جدران
الاوعيه الدمويه الصغيره والحد من قدره
الدم على التخثر وقدرت الدوائر الصحيه
نسبه الوفيات نتيجه الفيروس الى ما يقارب
اربعين بالمئه واقع الصحي يعني ينظر بخطر
وبالتالي يفترض ان تكون هناك مجاميع طبيه
وصحيه تتابع المواطن وبؤر يعني ظهرت فيها
هذه الجرثومه وهذه العشره
لمكافحتها وايضا توعيه الناس وتوعيه
المواطنين ويعني دور الحكومه المحليه ان
يكون لها دور واسع ودور كبير
حل سوى الوقايه وهو ما تنصح به المنظمات
الطبيه السكان المحليين وضروره التزامهم
بالتعليمات الصحيه للحد من مخاطر الوباء
وانتشاره لقناتي العربيه والحدث شاكر عواد
الناصريه